er hat eine glänzende karriere aus
molekulargenetiker aufgegeben zugunsten
eines kaufen lebens in einem kloster in
nepal
er lernte wie seine bücher und
regelmäßig bestseller er ist ein enger
vertrauter und übersetzer des dalai lama
und neuropsychologen haben ihn zum
glücklichsten menschen der welt erklärt
mattrick
der buddhistische mönch nimmt sich zeit
für ein gespräch mit mir hier in paris
wo er aufgewachsen ist
warum ist musiker wenn ich so glücklich
werden möchte wie sie womit sollte ich
heute noch anfangen
sie können die glücklichste frau der
welt werden wenn sie das glück dort
suchen wo es sich befindet
das problem ist auch dass man ihm den
rücken kehrt man wünscht sich das glück
aber man wendet sich von ihm ab man
möchte nicht leiden aber oft läuft man
auf das leiden zu doch was ihrer
einleitung betrifft es war nicht die
neurowissenschaftler die mich den
glücklichsten menschen der welt nannten
es waren die journalisten einen solchen
scherz würde sich die wissenschaften
nicht erlauben das stammt aus einem
dokumentarfilm eines australischen
fernsehsenders der gedreht wurde während
wir in madison mit ritscher davidson die
auswirkungen der meditation auf das
gehirn studierten insbesondere wenn
meditierende wie ich und manche andere
über die altruistische die nächstenliebe
meditiert
da werden gewisse bereiche des gehirns
intensiv aktiviert viel intensiver als
das was die neurowissenschaft bisher
hatte messen können
das betraf vor allem nicht und ein gutes
dutzend weiterer meditierenden männer
frauen mönche und laien aus ost und west
an mir war also nichts besonderes und es
ging auch nicht ums glück sondern um das
mitgefühl und die altruistische liebe
und in diesem dokumentarfilm heißt es
nun im kommentar
dieser mensch ist vielleicht der
glücklichste der welt daraus hat eine
englische tageszeitung eine schlagzeile
gemacht und die hat sich dann überall
verbreitet daran ist also nichts
wissenschaftliches aber interessant ist
ja schon dass in diesen studien auch an
der university of wisconsin unter diesem
professor richard action da wurde schon
klar dass eben in ihrem hirn ganz
spezielle dinge ablaufen und sieht doch
dass die wirklich die morphologie die
struktur des sehens sich verändert haben
der mandelkern war offenbar kleiner der
ist zuständig für die regulierung der
angst also offenbar hart meditation doch
enorme effekte auf das menschliche
gehirn ist das ist ganz bestimmt
und die ist nicht nur bei mir sondern
bei allen die ihren geist trainieren
am anfang wurden diese studien natürlich
an person gemacht die zwischen 10.000
und 60.000 stunden meditiert hatten
da sieht man tatsächlich funktionale und
strukturelle veränderungen in
hirnregionen die ihr volumen und ihre
dichte verändern
man stellt auch physiologische
veränderungen fest etwa eine stärkung
des immunsystems
was aber vielleicht für die menschheit
noch interessanter ist ist der umstand
dass man gesehen hat dass vier ja sogar
schon zwei wochen meditation von täglich
30 minuten zum beispiel über das
mitgefühl bereits das soziale verhalten
stärken
die entzündungsreaktion vermindern und
auch wie sie gesagt haben bereits nach
zwei wochen ein wenig die größe des
mandelkern verringern damit angst und
zorn mit angriffs und flucht reflexen
also mit instinktiven regen und zu tun
hat man sieht also dass es keine 50.000
stunden meditation braucht man stellt
sehr schnell veränderungen fest
meditieren
nehmen wir mal an man könnte diese
veränderung des gehirns auch erreichen
mit einer kleinen operation würden sie
sagen das ist auch zulässig oder gehen
hier der weg ist das ziel
das wäre eine zu starke vereinfachung
eine operation von was einen teil des
gehirns amputieren
wenn sie einen teil des gehirns
herausschneiden kommt das nicht gut
heraus im allgemeinen sind die folgen
katastrophal
es geht ja nur um einen kleinen teil des
gehirns die wichtigste eigenschaft des
gehirns ist dass zwischen seinen region
ein ständiger durchgehender und
synchrone austausch stattfindet es gibt
im gehirn keinen kontroll posten es gibt
kein ich als kommandostelle es gibt
nicht eine region für das mitgefühl oder
für das glück alles ist miteinander
vernetzt
für jeden gemütszustand für jede art des
denkens und die angst in zorn die
überraschungen die freude die
traurigkeit das mitgefühl der empathie
ist es immer ein zusammenspiel von
regionen die miteinander in eine
entsprechende beziehung treten
darum ist die idee dass man da
elektroden einsetzen könnte unmöglich es
braucht ein umfassendes einüben der
funktion des gesamten bewusstseins man
ihnen zuhört dass sie die materie ganz
genau kennen sie sind ja eigentlich auch
ursprünglichen naturwissenschaftler und
wenn wir über ihren weg sprechen dann
ist es tatsächlich so dass sie eine
große karriere aufgegeben haben als
molekulargenetiker sie haben angst die
pasteur studiert promoviert bei einem
nobelpreisträger und irgendwann war es
soweit sie gesagt haben jetzt ist hier
fertig mein weg geht hier nicht weiter
sondern mein weg geht weiter in nepal
und sie haben ihre sachen gepackt wie
ist es dazu gekommen
ja ich spreche lieber von koffer packen
alles von verzicht denn verzichten das
bedeutet so etwas wie eine tür zu
knallen im bett lag
mir gefällt das bild von der reise
besser man ist in einem tal steigt auf
einen hügel entdeckt ein neues tal und
steigt da hinunter entdeckt etwas neues
es ist aber nicht so dass man das
vorherige tangiert gering geschätzt oder
darauf verzichtet hat es folgt einfach
eine neue etappe im leben was mich zu
meinem schritt bewegte war folgendes in
meiner jugend hatte ich viel glück dank
meinem vater einem philosophen und
meiner mutter einer malerin sowie meinem
onkel einem entdecker ich selbst machte
klassische musik das gab die
wirkungsstätten bedeutender
wissenschaftler
so lernt sich eine reihe von
persönlichkeiten kennen die eine jede in
ihrem bereich große kapazitäten bahn
großen mathematiker große künstler
doch merkwürdigerweise gab es keine
entsprechung in dem sinne dass zum
beispiel ein großer mathematiker auch
ein guter mensch sein musste unter 100
gärtnern 100 musikern und 100
philosophen fand man überall gleich viel
äußerst warmherzige sympathische wie
auch sehr schwierige menschen
da gab es keinen zusammenhang als sich
hingegen nach indien aufbrach um den
großen spirituellen lehrer nnte begegnen
die aus dem besetzten tibet geflohen
waren kam es mir vor als gäbe es da 20
so gratis 20 franz von assisi in unserer
zeit lebten
da fand ich die vollkommene
übereinstimmung zwischen dem was sie
lehren und dem was sie leben ein großer
spiritueller lehrer der wütendes das
geht nicht
der botschafter muss gleichzeitig die
botschaft sein zu jeder zeit muss diese
person das verkörpern was sie vertritt
und was ihn ehrt das ist inspirierend
man bemüht sich nicht einfach klavier zu
spielen die eine bestimmte person man
strebt danach möglichst das zu werden
was diese person ist gerufen hat sie
eigentlich nicht eine theorie oder die
der wunsch auszusteigen sondern es waren
personen die sie begeistert haben
aussteigen das tut man aus einer welt in
der man keine befriedigung
findet wo man das tägliche streben nach
reichtum und ruhm satt hat weil es keine
erfüllung bringt mir war es vielmehr
eine positive inspiration
die fand menschen welche die weisheit
das mitgefühl die innere freiheit und
eine wachheit verkörperten und es hat
mich mehr inspiriert als das studium der
bakteriellen zellteilung nichts gegen
die bakterielle zellteilung
aber mir schien ein besserer mensch zu
werden dass er ein besserer gebrauchen
einer existenz ihr vater sie haben ihn
schon erwähnt er war philosophie war in
frankreich eine ganz wichtige
intellektuelle stürmischen france waren
es gestorben 2006 sie haben mit ihm
zusammen auch ein buch geschrieben das
ein fulminanter erfolg in frankreich und
später in vielen anderen ländern war der
meinung der philosoph ein dialog
zwischen vater und sohn auch ein dialog
zwischen buddhismus und abendland und
dieser vater schreibt sie im vorwort
wenn es später auch in ihren büchern
dass er eigentlich am anfang auch
enttäuscht war ich sogar ein klein
bisschen verärgert war das schwierig für
sie aus sohn damit umzugehen dass der
vater von der großartigen karriere
seines sohnes geträumt hat er war nicht
böse aber enttäuscht und traurig er fand
das sei eine verschwendung
aber er hatte die größe daraus kein
drama zu machen denn ich mag keine
dramen
er war also überhaupt nicht glücklich er
hat sich sogar bei einem freund aus
geweint er glaubte dass ich daran sei
mein leben zu vertuschen
doch sehr bald sagte er du bist 26 du
kannst dein leben selber wählen wenn man
daran denkt was eltern sich für ihre
kinder wünschen
man sieht heute so viele eltern die
beunruhigt oder traurig sind weil ihre
heranwachsenden kinder nicht wissen was
sie mit ihrem leben anfangen sollen und
sich in alle möglichen exzesse stürzen
oder unmotiviert sind doch bald hat mein
vater begriffen dass ich erfüllt war vor
einer großen freude und begeisterung für
das was ich machte er sah dass ich mich
mit der erhaltung von texten
beschäftigte und in meinem neuen leben
aufblühte
was können sich wohlwollen der eltern
besseres wünschen
von nun an war er sehr beruhigt und wir
waren die böse aufeinander
er schreibt es auch im vorwort des
buches die einzigen wolken die über
unsere beziehung hinwegzogen waren jene
des indischen monsuns künstlerin und re
briten hat sie erwähnten gewissen
manifesten sie sind überhaupt in einer
sehr künstlerischen familien
aufgewachsen haben igor strawinsky
persönlich kennengelernt viele louis
daniel ging in ihrem haus ein und aus
viele ganz ganz berühmte
persönlichkeiten die sie auf ihrem weg
angetroffen haben wenn dir jetzt
überlegen sie hätten ein anderes leben
gehabt denken sie das alles hat
eigentlich dazu geführt dass sie diesen
weg gegangen sind war das hilfreich für
sie sich so zu entwickeln
oder denken sie ganz egal wie sie
aufgewachsen wären dieser innere ruf
hätte sich sozusagen zu ihrem entscheid
gebracht es heißt ja der flügelschlag
eines schmetterlings in brasilien kann
das wetter in europa verändern
jedes ereignis im leben rüttelt am
gleichgewicht
oder ist eine wegkreuzung die mich 49
jahre
die maler ja gelebt habe ist es äußerst
schwer zu sagen ob ich da wäre wo ich
bin denn damals etwas anders gelaufen
wäre
das war nicht vorauszusehen ich weiß nur
dass mich damals die dokumentarfilme
über die großen tibetischen meister die
ich als 20-jähriger sei außerordentlich
inspirierten ich glaube nicht dass meine
vergangenheit dabei eine große rolle
spielte
vielleicht lag es in meiner natur dass
mich diese bilder unglaublich
inspirierten und ich den wunsch
verspürte diese meister kennenzulernen
welchen einfluss die bekanntschaft mit
philosophen und künstlern hatte da gibt
es nicht zwingend einen zusammenhang
ich hätte eine arbeitersohn sein können
ich wollte medizin studieren habe dann
aber naturwissenschaften studiert ich
glaube es lag an der kraft dieser bilder
dass ich mich geworden bin unabhängig
von seiner sozialen herkunft
wenn ich die gleichen gene und die
gleiche mentale veranlagung gehabt hätte
hätten mich diese bilder auf jeden fall
inspiriert aber das sagt sich jetzt doch
hätte ich dann auch die gelegenheit
gehabt in einem bestimmten augenblick
diese bilder zu sehen
jedes ereignis hat seinen platz im leben
man kann die geschichte nicht
umschreiben ich weiß nicht was geschehen
wäre
der buddhismus und sie sind heute
buddhistischer mönch kennt ja die idee
der reinkarnation gibt es auch so etwas
wie die idee der vorher bestimmen oder
sind wir überhaupt frei darin was aus
uns wird
die frage ist viel komplexer als es den
anschein macht das wort reinkarnation
ist kulturell sehr betrachtet das erste
vorstellung dass eine persönlichkeit ein
ego von einer existenz der anderen
springt im buddhismus gibt es das ego im
jetzt nicht so kann es sich auch nicht
trainieren
das bewusstsein ist ein dynamischer
fluss von mentalen ereignissen es gibt
keine
wesenheit war zentrum dieses flusses
dass ein einzelnes losgelöstes ich wäre
da gibt es also kein individuum das sich
regen kann irrt die eigentliche frage
ist folglich die nach dem wesen des
bewusstseins das anerkennen heute sogar
philosophen und theologen und
neurowissenschaftler auch wenn sie
durchaus ihrer eigenen hypothesen und
vorstellungen haben das bewusstsein als
eine tatsache die aber von einer rein
reduktionistischen physikalischen warte
aus kaum zu erklären
sie stehen da im clinch mit jenen
philosophen die sagen dass dies eine
unzulässige vereinfachung sei die frage
ist sehr offen und weitreichend der
buddhismus sagt dass das universum ohne
anfang und ende ist und die
erscheinungen nicht aus dem nichts
kommen können dass eine stetige
transformation stattfindet und nicht
eine schöpfung aus dem nichts
desgleichen was das bewusstsein betrifft
kann dieses nicht aus dem nichts
entstehen und auch nicht ins nichts
zurückfallen alles befindet sich in
einer kontinuität das ist alles recht
kompliziert im gegenteil sogar der
philosoph bertrand russell sagt dass ein
universum ohne anfang zwar eine
schwierige vorstellung aber durchaus
nicht unvereinbar sei mit der logik was
logisch schwer vorstellbar ist ist ein
universum das angefangen hat aber woher
soll der kommen
im buddhismus heißt es auch eine million
von ursachen kann nicht zur existenz
bringen was nicht existiert
denn mit dem begriff des nichts versucht
man zu fassen
die abwesenheit der welt der
erscheinungen wäre das ist eine
intellektuelle betrachtungsweise die
abwesenheit der welt der erscheinungen
ist eine vorstellung
das konzept der abwesenheit kann nicht
eine ursache sein
man kann also sagen eine erste ursache
kann es logisch nicht geben denn eine
ursache ohne ursache macht keinen sinn
eine ursache die alle ursachen enthält
musste dauernd die gesamtheit der welt
erschaffen die pisten führten als sie
noch keine beziehung zum christentum und
zum islam hatten eine große logische
diskussion mit der hinduistischen
metaphysik um diesen begriff der ersten
ursache zu dekonstruieren und seine
unlogik zu beweisen und logica wie
bertrand russell sind der gleichen
ansicht
der buddhismus geht noch weiter weil er
sagt das problem ist nicht vom nichts zu
etwas wirklich existierenden überzugehen
der buddhismus sagt ähnlich wie die
antike physik die welt der erscheinungen
sind ereignisse nicht dinge sondern
beziehungen
die welt wird wohl in erscheinung sie
ist aber in wahrheit nicht so fest
gefügt wie wir sie wahrnehmen
sie entbehrt der eigentlichen existenz
aber sie erscheint das ist gar nicht so
unvereinbar mit der antiken physik denn
in der antiken physik gibt es die
dualität zwischen partikel und wälle
eine welle ist überall ein partikel hat
ihren ort eine erscheinung kann also
nicht wesens mäßig partikel und welle
sein weil die beiden unvereinbar sind
die erscheinung erscheint als dieses und
erscheint als jenes aber es entbehrt der
eigentlichen existenz das mag etwas
kompliziert sein aber der buddhismus
kennt das problem der schöpfung nicht
weil die welt der erscheinungen keine
feste realität
sie sind ein enger vertrauter und
übersetzer seiner heiligkeit des dalai
lama er wird in diesen tagen 80 jahre
aus werben und der dalai lama gilt ja
als erleuchteter dessen sogenannte body
sagt ja was heißt es ehrlich zu sein ich
bin nicht sein berater sondern sein
schüler und sein übersetzer erleuchtet
oder erweckt es heißt der buddha war
kein prophet und kein heiliger sondern
ein erweckte es heißt er sei aus dem
schlaf der unwissenheit erwacht
unwissenheit bedeutet nicht etwa das
telefonbuch nicht auswendig zu kennen
die unwissenheit ist eine verzerrung der
realität nämlich zu denken dass die
unbeständigen erscheinungen beständig
sein dass ihr eine eigentliche existenz
besessen zu denken dass es ein einzelnes
selbständiges ich im fluss des
bewusstseins gebe
dies alles ist eine verzerrung der
realität
diese verzerrung kann allmählich zum
leiden führen die erweckung oder
erleuchtung ist auch ein vollkommenes
wissen und dieses geht einher mit einer
ausmerzung der sogenannten geistigen
gifte warum gifte weil sie unser leben
und jenes der anderen vergiften hass
hass und neid und eifersucht hochmut und
arroganz gedankenlosigkeit all dies
führt unvermeidlich ins leiden der
erweckung bedeutet also vom zustand des
schlafes wo man erst klar wer all dieser
negativen gemütszustände ist zur inneren
freiheit zu gelangen
freiheit der erkenntnis ist vollkommen
frei sein von hass von habsucht neid und
so weiter
das ist der weg um der zustand
vollkommenen wissens von klarheit und
erleuchtung die nicht getrübt ist von
wolken des unwissens man sagt das sei
offenkundig
nehmen wir an der himmel sei 10 100
jahre lang von wolken bedeckt
und eines tages fegt der wind die wolken
weg blauer himmel sonnenschein
das ist offenkundig wenn keine spur von
hass herrscht von hochmut von neid dann
sind das die zeichen
daran ist nichts geheimnisvolles es ist
der höhepunkt der ausmerzung von
unwissenheit und geistigen giften
wir alle haben ja die gelegenheit im
buddhismus unser karma zu verbessern
also in dieser ganzen in diesem leben
den wir drin stecken
an diesem thema zu arbeiten so dass sie
eigentlich dann im nächsten leben
vielleicht auf einer höheren stufe rhein
kann weiß ich nicht das nächste leben
weil es ja eben sagen das ist keine
seelenwanderung aber korrigieren europa
der prädestination sie haben auch die
vorbestimmung angesprochen
damit ist nicht ein schicksal gemein
dass von einem göttlichen wesen
beschlossen wurde
das karma ist lediglich das gesetz von
ursache und wirkung wenn ich etwas in
die luft werfe fällt es wieder runter
werfe ich einen stein in die höhe fällt
mir auf den kopf wenn ich vergesse dass
ich den stein geworfen habe frage ich
warum ist mir ein stein auf den kopf
gefallen
das karma ist das gesetz von ursache und
wirkung von intensionen also ob ich eine
böse absicht habe oder eine gute es gibt
die gewöhnlichen gesetze von ursache und
wirkung schwerkraft zum beispiel wenn
ich etwas fallen
wer im chamer geht es um ursache und
wirkung im zusammenhang mit glück und
leid diese zustände werden größtenteils
durch unsere guten oder bösen absichten
verursacht
es geht also um einen teilbereich der
gesetze von ursache und wirkung der mit
glück und leid und deren ursachen zu tun
hat es handelt sich also nicht um eine
vorbestimmung sondern um die folgen der
vergangenheit von allem was ich in der
vergangenheit getan habe trage ich heute
die folge aber nichts ist mir auch immer
vor bestärkt ich selbst bin der
architekt meiner zukunft jeden tag stehe
ich am scheideweg gehe ich hin auf
hinunter nach rechts oder nach links
die frage ist also nicht die nach all
den künftigen leben sondern nach diesem
weg ein besserer mensch zu werden
bedeutet in erster linie das wohl der
anderen zu gewährleisten und deren
leiden zu lindern
durch altruismus und mitgefühl und es
ist auch das beste mittel das wir selbst
in unserem dasein aufblühen wenn die
jagd nach einem egoistischen glück
funktioniert nicht sie haben in diesem
buch etwas glück stellen sie sehr schön
da was es alles braucht um eine
glückliche existenz zu leben vor einem
buddhistischen hintergrund wobei es kein
buch ist bei dem es allein um den
buddhismus geht sondern soll auch eine
anleitung sein etwas zum putzen von
buddhismus zu lernen denn man selber
nicht gut ist ist aber wenn man dieses
glück jetzt im heutigen leben für sich
realisieren möchte dann ist es
eigentlich gar nicht mehr so sehr das
ziel sozusagen für spätere existenzen
das karma zu verbessern sondern es geht
immer auch um unser leben dass wir heute
glücklich sind
es geht um beides wenn sie die ursachen
des leidens vermeiden wollen gilt dies
für heute für morgen für ein ganzes
leben
und wenn sie sich vorstellen dass es
noch weitere leben geben wird so gilt
das auch für alle kommenden leben
es ist immer eine frage von ursache und
will
die einen handlungen gedanken oder worte
bringen leiden für andere oder für uns
selbst die anderen bringen glück das ist
ein ewiges gesetz ich bin buddhistischer
mönch und bin damit glücklich und ich
halte mich an meine geistigen lehrer und
dieses buch wie auch das neue buch über
den altruismus an dem ich fünf jahre
gearbeitet habe und dass demnächst auch
auf deutsch heraus kommt hat ein mensch
geschrieben der sowohl wissenschaftler
als auch buddhistischer mönch ist
ich habe dabei versucht ein möglichst
breites spektrum abzudecken und alles zu
prüfen was über das glück geschrieben
wurde aus philosophischer
naturwissenschaftlicher soziologischer
psychologischer sicht
ich habe mir diesen plan über den
altruismus führe ich an einer stelle
auch die sichtweise des buddhismus an
aber es ist kein buch über den
buddhismus es wurde von einem menschen
geschrieben zu einem großen thema das
glück oder der altruismus
ich habe mich in allen disziplinen
umgesehen nach den interessantesten
elementen über die ursachen des glücks
eines der größten missverständnisse
scheint mir zu sein dass glück sei
identisch mit dem vergnügen flügel ist
gut und recht aber es gewährt keineswegs
das glück nehmen wir eine überaus
angenehme situation etwa eine heiße
dusche nach einer bergtour äußerst
angenehm aber stünden wir 24 stunden
unter einer heißen dusche wäre das
überhaupt nicht mehr angenehm das
vergnügen wechselt ist flüchtig nutzt
sich ab und es ist nicht dasselbe wie
das glück das glück ist eine science
weise die sich aus einem zusammenspiel
von eigenschaften ergibt für
altruistischen liebe der inneren
freiheit der seelen stärke dem inneren
frieden
gesagt haben dazu auch bücher
geschrieben der umgang mit den tieren
ist ihnen wichtig dass wir fair umgehen
mit ihren dass wir tiere das wohl der
tiere auch mit einbeziehen müssen denn
die tiere in dieser ganzen kette des
wiedergeboren werden zuerst auch ein
mensch werden oder kann ein tier direkt
auch erleuchtet werden
oder steigen alle auf langsam in diesem
rat die ja die menschen aller lebewesen
mit einem bewusstsein sind aus der sicht
des buddhismus beseelte wesen und sie
sind wesens mäßig gleich wie butter es
gibt keinen unterschied
sie haben lediglich mehr oder weniger
möglichkeiten dieses wesen zur geltung
zu bringen
es ist wie mit einem goldklumpen dem
boden vergraben liegt man muss ihn
ausgraben waschen und polieren damit er
in vollem glanz erstrahlt dafür braucht
es eine unterweisung man muss darüber
nachdenken meditieren sie verinnerlichen
tiere sind lebewesen die diese
eigenschaft besitzen aber nicht die
möglichkeit haben sie zur geltung zu
bringen
das heißt also dass die menschliche
existenz außerordentlich wertvoll ist
weil sie möglich macht dass man dank der
intellektuellen fähigkeiten einen weg
der verwandlung gehen unterweisungen
umsetzen und die erleuchtung allein kann
dabei ist aber zu sagen dass die tiere
keineswegs untergeordnete lesen sind mit
denen man machen kann was man will
hier stoßen wir auf einen enormen
ethischen zwiespalt in unserer zeit
wir haben zwar beachtliche fortschritte
auf dem gebiet der menschenrechte
erzielt
der wert des menschenlebens ist
praktisch unbegrenzt als unverhandelbar
das menschliche leben darf man nicht
vermarkten wie zu zeiten der sklaverei
und auch wenn solches noch vorkommt ist
es weltweit vermehrten die achtung der
menschenrechte ist also nicht
hingegen weiß man aus der
evolutionslehre dass es eine
kontinuierliche entwicklung gibt und
dass diese lebewesen schmerzempfinden
und am leben bleiben und nicht leiden
wollen
trotzdem müssen wir den tieren keinerlei
wert an sich zu außer einem
kommerziellen da besteht also ein
enormer ethische widerspruch zwischen
der totalen achtung vor dem menschlichen
leben und der abwertung des tierischen
lebens zur bloßen handelsware
es werden jedes jahr 65 milliarden tiere
zu land und 1000 milliarden näheres
tiere getötet
zu unserem verzehr zu unserem vergnügen
für unsere bekleidung von daher dürfen
wir uns wohl kaum als eine zivilisation
mit einer kohärenten ethik betrachten
wenn wir diese frage nicht lösen
sie leben gänzlich t shirt gewiss der
grund warum ich vegan lebe ist weil ich
kein leiden essen will
ich will mich nicht ernähren vom leiden
und vom tod anderer umso weniger als
dies gar nicht nötig ist und allen
schadet zuerst den tieren dann aber auch
der umwelt die fleischproduktion ist mit
15 prozent die zweitgrößte quelle von
treibhausgasen die zur klimaerwärmung
beitragen gleich nach den behausungen
und noch vor dem verkehr
sie verschärft die armut weil 700
millionen tonnen getreide aus südamerika
und afrika an die reichen länder
verfrachtet werden
sie schadet auch der menschlichen
gesundheit
wir sehen also alle verlieren dabei ihr
leben ausgestaltet nach welchen regeln
müssen sie ihren alltag gestalten
vegetarier oder veganer zu sein ist
keine monastische riegel sondern eine
persönliche
in unserem kloster verwenden wir zwar
keine tierischen produkte aber das ist
keine vorschrift hingegen gibt es
grundlegende regeln nicht nur für mönche
sondern für jeden buddhisten zum
beispiel nicht zu töten nicht zu lügen
wie auch sonst jede einfache und
natürliche ethische regeln
[Musik]
ich persönlich habe dass man nicht leben
gewählt um die freiheit zu finden
wenn ich eine familie hätte könnte ich
mich nicht für jahre in die berge
zurückziehen weil ich dann meinen
unrecht hätte ich habe also diese
freiheit gewählt aber das ist eine sehr
besondere wahl
man braucht überhaupt nicht mehr nicht
zu werden um den geistigen vater zu
beschreiten
zwei meiner wichtigsten lehrer waren
keine mönche und hatten familie was
meines leben ist zwar keine kleinigkeit
aber es ist eine persönliche
entscheidung
man kann den buddhistischen weg in
seiner gesamtheit gehen bis zur
erleuchtung ohne mich zu werden die
meisten meiner freunde im westen die
sich drei sechs oder neun jahre
zurückgezogen haben sind im allgemeinen
keine mönche oder nonnen der buddhismus
sieht für mich so etwas wie auch ein
blick ins innere eine vertiefung und es
gibt immer auch einen anderen blick den
sie interessiert hat nämlich der blick
durch die linse
sie sind nämlich auch fotograf und sie
sind ein so guter fotograf dass einer
der ganz großen fotografen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wie cartier
bresson sie schlussendlich eigentlich zu
seinem freund auch gemacht hat er hat
ihnen auch ein buch gewidmet
wie ist dieser blick durch die linse
entstanden für sie jetzt sind sie
fotograf geworden
das bedeutet ihnen das fotografieren
oder böse der preis zuerst ging es mir
vor allem darum die schönheit dessen zu
dokumentieren was ich sah die schönheit
derer denen ich begegnet
die innere schönheit meiner geistigen
lehrer um sie zu dokumentieren
aber auch die schönheit der natur um in
bezug auf die menschliche natur etwas
hoffnung zu verbreiten
wir tendieren sehr dazu nur die
schattenseiten der menschlichen natur zu
sehen und zu sagen wie grund schlecht
und egoistisch der mensch sei das ist
natürlich reine ideologie denn keine
wissenschaftliche studie hat jede
hypothese des universellen egoismus
gestützt um also die hoffnung zu
verbreiten dass wir in uns das potenzial
zur güte und zum altruismus haben muss
man gesichter zeigen welche diese liebe
und dieses mitgefühl ausdrücken und auch
um die harmonie der natur zu zeigen weil
er die große herausforderung unserer
zeit das umweltproblem ist wir
entscheiden heute über das schicksal der
künftigen generationen bei der
geschwindigkeit in der wir heute
vorangehen werden bis 2050 30 prozent
der arten verschwunden sein
die menschen zu inspirieren und sie
entzücken von der schönheit der natur
und von der schönheit derer die dieses
mitgefühl und diese weisheit ausstrahlen
das bedeutet hoffnung zu geben dafür
habe ich diese bilder gemacht mit ihnen
ansehen dass mich sehr berührt hat es
ist aus ihrem kloster session in nepal
was sind wir was machen diese mönche das
ist der schluss einer großen feier die
acht tage und acht nächte ohne
unterbrechung dauert tagsüber von 7 uhr
morgens bis sieben uhr abends sind alle
500 mönche des klosters zugegen und in
der nacht wechseln sie sich gruppenweise
ab man schläft jeder nacht etwa drei
stunden
am letzten tag gibt es draußen vor dem
kloster eine prozession wie man hier
sieht
leider wurde jetzt dieses kloster durch
das erdbeben in nepal stark beschädigt
dann wird das größtenteils wieder
aufbauen müssen das wollte ich sie auch
noch fragen dieses furchtbare erdbeben
oder die mehreren erdbeben die sich
ergeben haben in nepal fast 9000
todesopfer gefordert haben viele dörfer
sind zerstört wie ist das für sie als
buddhist im christentum war das immer
ein großes thema so genannte theodizee
problem wie kann man gott rechtfertigen
angesichts so furchtbaren ereignisse
wenn gott doch allmächtige gütig und
allwissend ist müsste er das verhindern
können
wie geht ein buddhist mit solchen
furchtbaren ereignis hat kein problem
mit dieser frage das ist das natürliche
gesetz von ursache und wirkung da ist
niemand der beschlossen hat dass diese
wesen leiden sollten
das ist ein naturereignis leider
geschehen erdbeben oft hingegen wird der
buddhist sein mitgefühl in die tat um
ich selbst habe insgesamt fünf jahre
einsamkeit in einsiedeln verbracht und
versucht mich in mitgefühl zu üben
nun könnte man sagen diese fünf jahre
bringen der menschheit nicht viel aber
wenn man dann das was man eingeübt hat
versucht in den dienst der anderen zu
stellen dann ist das doch von nutzen
ich habe vor etwa 15 jahren zusammen mit
dem abt des klosters die organisation
carola setzen ins leben gerufen
karuna heißt mit gefühl und wir pflegen
heute 120 tausend patienten pro jahr in
verschiedenen kliniken die wir in tibet
nepal und indien gebaut haben 25.000
kinder gehen in schulen die wir gebaut
haben
wir haben in nepal eine klinik mit 50
personen und dazu noch mönche die sich
ihnen angeschlossen haben uns beim
erdbeben konnten unsere leute 178 1000
personen in 450 dörfern hilfe leisten
jede dieser rund 180.000 personen
nahrungsmittel für zwei wochen ärztliche
hilfe und schutz zelte als nächstes
gehen wir nun an den wiederaufbau der
schulen und andere einrichtungen
wir handeln also auch langfristig um den
erdbebenopfern in den dörfern rund um
kathmandu zu helfen ich jetzt mal darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass in vielerlei
hinsicht der buddhismus im grunde
genommen den anderen religionen
vielleicht vorzuziehen ist weiß es
dieses gottes problem nicht gibt es gibt
kein theodizee problem es gibt kein
problem mit dem anfang und dem ende des
universums
tatsächlich haben ja viele philosophen
das auch so gesehen schopenhauer war
einer der den buddhismus aus bessere
religion sich vorgestellt hat den
christentum vorzuziehen um miete
schlussendlich hat auch gesagt gott ist
tot deswegen ist eigentlich die religion
des buddhismus eine religion ohne gott
und eine bessere religion ist für sie
der buddhismus überhaupt eine religion
oder ist das eigentliche sophie auch
einstein sagte dass ihn unter den
religionen der buddhismus am meisten
anziehen
ich finde es einen großen irrtum zu
behaupten dass eine religion den anderen
überlegen sei wie auch der dalai lama
sagt keine religion und keinen
spiritualität wird die alle
zufriedenstellen wenn alle restaurants
der welt das gleiche gericht anbieten
würden gingen die leute nicht oft ins
restaurant die verschiedenen
spiritualität und religionen entsprechen
den verschiedenen bedürfnissen und
veranlagungen der menschen mann soll
seinen eigenen weg gehen in vollem
respekt für die anderen menschen und
deren religionen die ihren veranlagungen
besser entsprechen ist der buddhismus
eine religion oder nicht
der dalai lama pflegt zu sagen die
philosophen nennen den buddhismus eine
religion welche die philosophie
ausschließt und die religionen sagen der
buddhismus ist eine philosophie welche
die religion ausschließt der buddhismus
befindet sich also vielleicht weder da
noch dort aber das erlaubt ihm eine
brücke zu schlagen
der buddhismus ist ein weg der
verwandlung er führt vom leiden zur
befreiung vom leiden vom unwissen zur
erleuchtung vom egoismus zum mitgefühl
diesem bild der speisekarte bleiben und
sagen es gibt so was wie eine
speisekarte der religionen dann werden
die gerichte des buddhismus zurzeit sehr
oft konsumiert ein gutes beispiel dafür
ist die sogenannte achtsamkeit bewegung
meint fundes das ist ein großer trend
und anderem inspiriert von jon kabat
zinn dem amerikaner der diese ganze
bewegungen eigentlichen losgetreten hat
oder transformiert hat und in vielen
firmen werden mittlerweile achtsamkeit
kurse angeboten unter anderem beim it
unternehmen sap
wir sehen einen ausschnitt aus dem film
mit die neue achtsamkeit den die
sternstunde religion heute morgen
gezeigt hat die besonderheit des kurses
sehen wir hier eingeführt haben ist dass
der halt das sehr gut erklärt warum ist
es im business kontext hilfreich und der
neue punkt ist dass mit diesen trainings
die wir anbieten basierend auf mein
volles die emotionale intelligenz
gesteigert wird und daraus leitet sich
der business case habt warum ist das
unternehmen gut
und warum ist es gleichermaßen für den
mitarbeiter gut achtsamkeit bei sap hier
in deutschland heimisch meint peter hat
es in den usa angefangen
mir war es wichtig nach deutschland zu
bringen weil es mehrere merkmale hat die
uns sehr helfen werden in der zukunft
ich will nicht sagen dass hier eine
schlechte stimmung ist aber es ist doch
eine umbruchsituation die stress und
druck bei den leuten verursacht und da
verspreche ich mir von diesen
achtsamkeitstraining zu den anderen
umgang mit dieser situation wenn die
leute über diese achtsamkeit trainings
in der lage sind in konfliktsituationen
oder in stresssituationen auf ihr
gesamtes potenzial zuzugreifen
weil sie nicht mehr blockiert sind dann
sind sie effektiver im berufsalltag sie
können mehr erreichen sie können mehr
leisten dass wir das auch mit diesem
argument verkaufen können und nicht nur
sagen wir machen irgendwie was gutes was
schönes was edles und das ist auch
knaller betriebswirtschaftlich sinnvoll
da bin ich felsenfest davon überzeugt
hat dass wir sie noch etwas zu tun mit
dem kern des buddhismus mit dieser idee
der meditation die so wichtig ist
jon kabat zinn einer meiner freunde hat
mit diesen übungen der stress minderung
durch achtsamkeit im krankenhaus milieu
angefangen vor 35 jahren stellte er in
spitälern fest die leute litten sehr
unter stress und zwar sowohl patienten
wie pflegepersonal er glaubte diese art
von intervention könnte ihr leiden
lindern
das programm dauerte acht wochen
gemeinsam entspannten sich die leute
machten etwas yoga und atmeten in
achtsamkeit
das löst sie ihre ängste und ihren
stress da herrscht natürlich immer auch
die gute absicht das leiden zu lindern
das wurde zu einem weltweiten erfolg
und es ist sicher von großem nutzen aber
natürlich kann niemand behaupten rest
ist die essenz des buddhismus sei es ist
eine sehr nützliche technik der aus dem
buddhismus stammt die aber nicht für den
ganzen buddhismus steht im krankenhaus
milieu ist das unproblematisch denn es
geht ja darum leiden zu lindern
wenn sie nun in einem unternehmen das
lindern was diese leute nannten nämlich
stress spannungen gut aber er sprach
auch von effizienzsteigerung
sie sehen das kann verschiedenen zwecken
dienen
ich habe einen freund der etwa 100
führende leute von großen firmen
befragte die sich zu einer achtsamkeit
meditation begeben hatten zu beginn
sagten sie sie fürchteten zeit zu
verlieren und weniger effizient zu sein
aber dann geschah was sie nicht
erwarteten ihre menschlichen beziehungen
verbesserten sich und ebenso ihre
urteilskraft weil sich ihr horizont
weitet nun riskiert aber die achtsamkeit
die einfach im dienste der firma steht
ihrer komponente der rechten gesinnung
beraubt zu werden
man kann sich ja auch einen achtsamen
söldner vorstellen der mit seinem gewehr
schießt er ist voll und ganz bei sich er
hat seine gefühle unter kontrolle
er urteilt nicht denn er tötet alle er
kann auch ein psychopath sein
man muss also unbedingt von der
achtsamkeit in der rechten gesinnung
sprechen denn einen söldner mit rechter
gesinnung das gibt es nicht und auch
einen psychopathen mit rechter gesinnung
nicht
ich habe neulich bei großen
amerikanischen firmen gesprochen welche
die achtsamkeit praktizieren und ich
sagte ihnen bitte führt von anbeginn weg
diese komponente der rechten gesinnung
ein und denkt nicht dass sich dieser
automatisch einstellen wird
dh es geht eigentlich darum einfach ein
bisschen ruhig zu werden und effizienter
zu sein vielleicht besser schlafen zu
können sondern sollte immer gekoppelt
sein an touristische momente das
wiederum ist für mich steht für mich in
einer gewissen spannung zur
interpretation des buddhismus wie wir
ihn auch immer wieder hier diskutieren
in unseren breitengraden max weber der
große soziologe hat man gesagt oh dies
muss ist eine theorie der welt
verneinung er ist zwar sehr edel aber
ist eigentlich sehr politisch wenn sie
sagen er hat den buddhismus vollkommen
falsch verstanden dass
eine verdrehung wer hat das gesagt
im neunzehnten und am anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts herrschte ein
totales missverständnis er bezug auf den
buddhismus weber fantini listig
gleichgültig der welt gegenüber
dabei betrachtet der buddhismus den
idealismus als einen schweren irrtum nun
er war sicher sehr klug auf seinem
gebiet aber er hat den buddhismus nicht
verstanden
der buddhismus spricht er von der
realität als etwas das erscheint das
also nicht dass nichts ist das aber der
eigentlichen existenz entbehrt er ist
also auch nicht der nackte realismus
denn die erscheinungen manifestieren
sich entbehren aber der eigentlichen
existenz es ist also weder nihilismus
noch realismus andererseits gibt es auch
niemals die gleichgültigkeit gegenüber
der welt wenn der kern das herz des
buddhismus ist nicht der achtsamkeit
sondern das mitgefühl
es ist die weisheit und die
altruistische liebe wie die beiden
flügel eines vogels wissen und weisheit
und die altruistische liebe das ist doch
keine gleichgültigkeit der welt
gegenüber
auch sehr wichtig weil sie glauben man
kann tatsächlich auch ein stück weit die
welt die ökonomie die politik verändern
zum guten hin wenn wir gewisse ideen des
buddhismus übernehmen das ist eine
initiative auch das meinen live
instituts eine initiative die auch seine
heiligkeit der dalai lama gegründet hat
sie sitzen da ein beirat es gibt ein
neues buch mitgefühl in der wirtschaft
das haben sie zusammen mit tania singer
herausgegeben da kann man nachlesen was
das für sie heißt in einem autistischen
sind wirtschaftlich tätig zu sein
glauben sie tatsächlich das ist
sozusagen ein weg mit dem wir die ganze
die ganze art und weise wie
zusammenleben transformieren können
es ist nicht der buddhismus ist das
mitgefühl das mitgefühl ist nicht das
eigentum des buddhismus mitgefühl und
altruismus sind viel grundlegender die
religionen der buddhismus dass christ
der islam das judentum sie alle
propagieren die liebe auf einer zweiten
ebene auf der ersten ebene wendet sich
die liebe an alle menschen seien sie
buddhisten oder nicht christen oder
agnostiker oder atheisten
wir alle haben das bedürfnis liebe und
mitgefühl zu geben und zu bekommen das
ist an keine religion gebunden ist ein
grundbedürfnis jedes menschen müsste man
nämlich die wirtschaftlichen probleme
mit dem buddhismus lösen käme man
nirgendwohin der altruismus ist etwas
ganz anderes
das ist ganz einfach die rechte
gesinnung die rechte gesinnung ist
selbstverständlich der kern des
buddhismus aber auch des christentums
und jeder anderen religion
lassen wir also die religion beiseite
warum ist der altruismus heute so
wesentlich weil wir mühe haben drei
zeitvorstellungen unter einen hut zu
bringen
die kurzfristigkeit der wirtschaft alles
geht schnell tage monate der abschluss
am jahresende dann die mittelfristig
kite die lebensqualität was mache ich
aus meinem leben wie erlebe ich meine
lebensqualität als frustration oder als
entfaltung und schließlich die
langfristigkeit sie ist eine neue
herausforderung für die menschheit weil
es um das schicksal der kommenden
generation geht
vor 10.000 jahren gab es zwischen einer
und fünf millionen menschen auf der welt
das für unproblematisch
heute sind wir sieben milliarden und
unsere wissenschaftlichen und
technischen möglichkeiten auf die umwelt
einzuwirken haben sich verzehnfacht
wenn aber umweltexperten mit ökonomen
reden sprechen sie nicht die gleiche
sprache was in 50 jahren geschehen wird
interessierte ökonom nicht
es braucht also ein konzept um das kurz
das mittel und das langfristige
miteinander zu verbinden das einzige
funktionierende konzept ist der
altruismus wenn wir die mitmenschen
vermehrt in unserer abwägung einbeziehen
schaffen wir die sogenannten caring
economics das heißt eine solidarische
wirtschaft der rechten gesinnung
wir können die armut aus dem reichtum
heraus bekämpfen und uns den gemeinsamen
kindern widmen
der qualität der luft der meere und der
umwelt der homo oeconomicus der nur
seine eigenen interessen verfolgt kann
dies nicht mehr tun
mit mehr als rosmus verbessern wir das
zusammenleben die gerechtigkeit
vermindern das soziale gefälle und
kümmern uns vermehrt um die kommenden
generationen diese vision die sie haben
keinen sie ja auch ein stück weit mit
ernst fehr der eben dieses homo
oeconomicus modell immer wieder
kritisiert hat und für den autos muss
ein steht der vorstand der universität
zürich
aber wie kriegen sie die leute zu diesem
umdenken von dem sie träumen
es ist ganz anders
ernst fehr hat ja gezeigt dass drei
viertel der menschen bereit wären nett
zu machen das problem ist wenn es keine
regulierung gibt werden die profiteure
das system ist brauchen wir müssen also
ein geeignetes klima schaffen damit die
menschen die bereit sind mitzumachen und
einander zu vertrauen dies tun können
es braucht also regulierungen und
leitplanken ein anderer deutscher ökonom
dennis snower präsident des instituts
für weltwirtschaft in kiel spricht von
diesen kern economics er sagt dass der
homo oeconomicus die armut niemals aus
dem reichtum heraus besiegen kann
das große problem aber ist nun einmal
das soziale gefälle
dieses hat in den letzten 30 jahren in
allen oecd ländern zugenommen der
altruismus ist auch der einzige währung
der umweltproblematik zu begegnen
der egoismus kann dieses problem nicht
lösen in 100 jahren werden weder sie
noch ich mir hier sein wenn uns die
künftigen generation egal sind gibt es
freilich kein umweltproblem
es ist eine reine frage von egoismus
oder altruismus die großen ökonomen wie
joseph stiglitz der von der ungleichheit
spricht plädieren für eine humanere
altruistische wirtschaft das ist nicht
nur ein nobler gedanke sondern eine
notwendigkeit die egoistische wirtschaft
kann die probleme unserer zeit nicht
lösen
und trotzdem beginnt es ja bei jedem
individuum und ich habe kürzlich von
ihnen auf twitter dieses diesen tweet
gesehen da sagen sie 10 sekunden einer
meditation ist so etwas wie zehn
sekunden parfüm zu riechen
zehn sekunden meditation pro tag das
wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht reichen
was empfehlen sie den menschen denn sie
jetzt eine empfehlung abgeben können was
sollen sie in ihrem leben ändern damit
sich die weltstadt endlich vereint wird
idealerweise sollte man täglich fünf
sechs stunden meditieren sie 10 sekunden
sind nicht meine erfindung
das sagt einer meiner freunde heißt
chaitman arbeitet bei google und hat das
projekt search inside your self
aufgebaut
er ist meditationslehrer in google
unternehmen bei diesen gehetzt leuten
wie man sich vorstellen kann
er hat sich gefragt was man da machen
können zehn sekunden das hört sich ja
idiotisch aber es ist viel schlauer als
es aussieht stellen sie sich vor
jede stunde halten sie für zehn sekunden
innen nur zehn sekunden
sie fallen niemandem um den hals weil es
ja nicht immer gut ankommt besonders auf
der straße aber während zehn sekunden
fragen sie sich ist dieser mensch wohl
glücklich ist jener gesund hat er ein
erfülltes leben ist er frei von hürden
und leiden und auch jene die ihm teuer
sind
das denken sie aufrichtig zehn sekunden
lang und eine stunde später wieder
dasselbe sie sagen zehn sekunden das
wirkt doch nicht doch öffnen sie mal
eine parfümflasche zehn sekunden lang
und verschließen sie sie dann wieder der
duft bleibt zehn minuten lang in der
luft wenn sie es oft genug wiederholen
bleibt der duft vielleicht für immer
es löst in ihnen eine andere
geisteshaltung aus wohlwollender
altruistischer wenn sie zehn sekunden
lang aufrichtig das wohl eines
mitmenschen gewünscht haben werden sie
ihn danach nicht gleich ohrfeigen
sie werden ein wenig in diesem
wohlwollend beharken
es ist also eine methode einem fluss in
gang zu halten der den gang
tag andauert wer das ausprobiert hat hat
festgestellt dass man das während der
arbeit machen kann und dass man die
andern anders wahrnimmt und sich die
beziehungen verbessern
das ist etwas für die hektische moderne
welt wenn man aber ernsthaft meditieren
will ist eine halbe oder eine ganze
stunde besser und bisweilen auch eine
zeit des rückzugs da verändert man sich
viel tiefgreifender etwas anderes was
mich sehr interessiert dass sie auch an
verschiedenen stellen beschreiben
sie sagen man soll aufhören dauernd
seine gefühle herauszulassen mutter
spricht er davon dass die gefühle wie
eine affenhorde herumtanzen wenn wir uns
nicht bemühen die gefühle irgendwie zu
zu zähmen und sie sagen an einer stelle
auch wir sollten uns irgendwie überlegen
ob es eigentlich so eine gute sache ist
immer zu sagen streit ist klärend wir
müssen auch unsere gefühle herauslassen
wie genau ist ein achtsamer umgang mit
den eigenen gefühlen oder und der
buddhismus haben nie gesagt dass mein
gefühle unterdrücken soll
wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen
destruktiven gefühlen sie uns betrieben
und leidenschaften und den
gemütszuständen welche glücklich machen
zum beispiel der zorn die animosität die
eifersucht
sie schaffen leidend für sie selbst und
für die mitmenschen
sie sollen also nicht zulassen dass die
eifersucht ihren geist erfasst
wenn sie aber altruistische liebe
empfinden soll diese im gegenteil ihren
ganzen geist erfassen
man sollte also unterscheiden zwischen
emotionen welche das eigene wohlbefinden
und das der anderen fördern und jenen
die das wohlbefinden zerstören die gift
sind für das eigene wohlbefinden und das
der anderen
diese emotionen müssen wir eliminieren
in der tat hat es eine zeit lang
geheißen wenn man eine große wut hat
soll man sie nicht unterdrücken man sei
es ihre auslassen nun haben
wissenschaftler gezeigt dass dies nicht
stimmt man wird dadurch fiel dem
zornigen öfter und stärker
man steigert ein zaun es war
man soll es auch nicht unterdrückt wie
eine zeit der buddhismus empfiehlt wir
etwa auch die kognitive
verhaltenstherapie einen intelligenten
dialog mit den emotionen
was kann ich tun damit die emotionen
aufsteigt und dann verfliegt einem vogel
ähnlich der am himmel vorbei zieht
ohne eine spur zu hinterlassen wir haben
damit die emotion weder unterdrückt noch
explodieren lassen sondern es verstanden
dass sie sich in dem augenblick löst das
ihr aufkommt anstatt unseren geist zu
störungen
es ist eine viel intelligentere park mit
den gefühlen umzugehen indem wir sie
verfliegen lassen bevor sie uns zum
sklaven machen ich habe sie am anfang
unseres gesprächs gefragt was ich mit
womit ich anfangen kann wenn ich so
glücklich werden möchte wie sie zum
schluss visier egal womit soll ich heute
noch aufhören wenn ich glücklich werden
möchte im besten fall sollten sie ihre
mitmenschen glücklich machen
das ist der beste weg mit dem glück der
anderen auch uns selbst glücklich zu
machen
zuallererst aber vermeiden sie es unter
allen umständen die anderen leiden zu
lassen
ja und mit diesem gespräch verabschieden
wir von der sternstunde philosophie uns
in die sommerpause
in den nächsten sieben wochen öffnen wir
für sie unsere schatztruhe und zeigen
ihnen unsere tiefgründigsten und
aufregendsten gespräche der letzten
zwölf monate noch einmal am 30 august
begrüße ich sie wieder in unserem
zürcher studio zu neuen sternstunden in
den namen jetzt aber einen schönen
sommer
[Musik]